the jurogan experience so i get picked
up in atlanta take me atlanta jail i go
and then put me in this modular and i go
in this module and there's black people
all the different races right well over
there they don't politic like we do in
california right so this my first
understanding of how this system works
right so i go in there and the only
thing that you can't do in that system
is you can't eat at the same table with
a different race
besides that once you're up from the
dinner table
i can trade with any race i could do
whatever talk to them chop it up but you
have to eat with people of your own race
only yeah
so then uh and they tell you this is so
so somebody informs you oh yeah oh yeah
i got informed when i went in when i
when i moved from atlanta to california
california politics much different you
can't trade you can't trade with with
blacks you can't trade with others you
can't trade with
so you can only do trade with your race
and then the whites get along with the
essays so what ended up happening is
like
so you have others which are any other
race besides mexican white or black
and this is a car it's called a car
right so everybody has a car their own
race so you have woods you have
skinheads you have paisas you got
mexicans you got crips bloods and others
and the pisces roll with the mexicans
the skin has rolled the woods yeah and
if something really pops off some races
click up then the mexicans in the and
the whites will click up against the
blacks and blacks it's always on them
against us it always sucked to be it's
sucked to be black in them times i'm
telling you really what we get hey but
we thumped though we thumped
so so we always knock them out you start
trying to figure out this [ __ ] you know
like you get thrown into that fire
trying to figure out all these unwritten
rules you know there's no rule book a
law book come in and say hey do this
this this this yeah you know right so a
guy could really direct you in the law
the wrong way if he wants to you know i
mean like tell you some sideways [ __ ]
and next thing you know you're in a
wreck
so i go and set you up so i go in um
this was actually my second experience
my first experience in there but my
second experience i go in they put me
into a psych ward a psych watch
getting extradited from atlanta to here
and uh so i go into this area and and i
don't know anything you know and
this black guy in the psych ward is like
yelling in this module you know like
anybody want to learn how to play chess
anybody want to learn how to play chess
you know i was like hell yeah i want to
learn how to play chess right
so i walk over i sit down with this fool
and he starts showing me how to play
chess but it's a black guy at a black
guy table and i'm a white guy so now i
just sat down with this black guy table
and all the woods and all the skinheads
and they're like now against me oh no no
but i didn't know like oh no you had no
idea i had no idea oh no right so now no
no yeah for bao
my cell pops and i go to walk to the
shower and i walk past the other cell
that pops which is another another
skinhead in that in that room and i go
walk past his his cell and his smack
right
so now we're fighting wow you know so
clean this kid up
now they moved me to another module
so now this kid put a kite out like oh
we got to get this guy
so oh fun
yeah so i'm moving this other module
at the time the the institution had a
lot of skinheads in there and the
skinheads were politic hard like if they
have numbers then they'll push the
politics you know
and
i look like a skinhead when i went in
there's no hair you know like it's just
bald guy going in there you know i mean
so they all
start treating me like i'm one of them
but i'm not a [ __ ] skin head so this
guy come over and he's trying to get me
to hide this little shank in my cell
well that's weapons manufacturing
carries two more years
oh my god this is how people start
getting hit
you start catching cases more cases when
you only put through two now you're
doing ten
it just stacks up go ahead and then
there's intimidation factor right so
this guy got a big ass swastika tattooed
on his face right here tear drops
lightning bolts everywhere you know what
i mean like this he's lifer you know
right so
big [ __ ] goes down we end up i end up
choking this guy unconscious oh jesus
christ drag him out of my cell because
he's trying to get me to hold this this
[ __ ] yeah myself i can't not not doing
this bro and you come in my cell it's on
right so now we're fighting
take this guy out right choke him out
beat him up
drag him out hit him with some elbows
and now he's leaking
so drag his ass out into the little
monster so do they know you can fight
before you're in no no no they have to
fit no how long before they figure it
out well it turns out traveling it took
a minute because most of the fighting
goes on in the cellar in a in a shower
you know i mean so when the fight
actually broke out in the open when
there was i was finding multiple people
is what happened and then
all the [ __ ] guards watched
everybody's watching from their cells
you know like this is a different time
so this whole incident takes place i
beat this guy up take him out of my my
cell right now
they take him away they move this guy
out of the module do they get mad at you
no they just come in you know they they
don't really care the guards real [ __ ]
they don't give a [ __ ] you [ __ ] that
dude up did is he out cold so does he
have a choke
do they have to ask him what his story
is
i don't give a [ __ ] they but they don't
they don't ask you they just let you go
it's okay
like is there a punishment that's what
i'm gonna
i couldn't get on myself for like two
weeks oh for two weeks yeah just alone
in yourself constantly nothing but your
store so what happens is for a certain
amount of hours of the day they gotta
pop the door and let you into a bigger
cell a bigger room you know what i mean
so
i just couldn't get into the the day
room for like two weeks but the crazy
[ __ ] of it all is like i'm trying to
tell you i'm trying to learn these this
system right this new rules so what
happens is this kid this guy okay we
talk about the cars and the races right
so each race has their own car which
means there's a key holder the key
holder to that car controls the race
so they make decisions for the race they
can keep other races out of car wrecks
like now we got a feud with the blacks
so we got a feud with the mexicans or
whatever they call them car wrecks yeah
well if we go get in a fight with them
the key holder is the guy that can
communicate with the other key holders
to the races and trying to delegate it
wow
yeah
and so i didn't had it happen where we
were going to get down with the mexicans
and then our keys would go and they keys
and we finished jumping getting ready to
jump and they and they shake hands all
right it ain't going it ain't going and
then it go back down so
yeah and you're trying to figure all
this out so what happened was i beat
this fool's ass and now i'm i got the
keys
oh wow but i can't have the keys because
i'm a first termer so first turner's not
allowed to have the keys but nobody
nobody wanted to try to take the keys
from me
so in order for them to take the keys
for me they got to fight me to take the
keys away from me oh boy so so
that kind of changed the dynamics of the
room because now i'm able to navigate
with these other races and have these
conversations with these [ __ ]
ignorant people that don't understand
how to how to really
talk you know what i mean like how to
communicate and and keep things cool
they they misunderstand what this guy
says or misinterpret what this guy says
the next thing you know it's hot for
everybody you know and it's just
misinterpretations yeah yeah cause
they're dumb most likely these guys are
dumb bro like they're
like the congress it made me in some
ways are you sitting there listening to
these guys you're like these guys really
think this [ __ ] like they talk about the
dumbest [ __ ] yeah so
cities fighting over
teams fighting over
this is the dumbest [ __ ] xbox and
playstation and somebody said something
wrong and then that escalated into
something that was personal yeah that's
quick so now they take me from there
that instant takes place right and we
resolve some of that stuff but
now these guys are in different modular
so now they're putting these kites out
to try and get me as i'm going to court
so what happens they catch chain with
some guys and then we go into these
holding tanks all these different
holding tanks and you get put in that
holding tank with that guy that got a
kite that's looking for you and now it's
on it's cracking you know what i mean
whoa so i'm sitting in my cell i'm
getting ready to go to court and there's
two huge ass guys and they're in there
talking to each other about trying to
get me
but they don't know that it's me
so i'm sitting in there i'm listening to
everything that they're trying to do and
how they're gonna try and set this [ __ ]
up and i'm sitting right in front of
them and they don't even realize it's me
wow and i'm thinking honestly i'm like
these are big [ __ ] i'm thinking
they're gonna take me out like there's
only so much you can do you know what i
mean numbers
so
i make it through that whole process and
i catch the chain and when i catch a
chain they take you from county to
to state
and i catch the chain with the same
[ __ ]
that i got into it with i took the keys
from
oh my goodness and this is like he's a
like been in the system a long time
right
so now we catch the chain we go over to
donovan rj donovan it's a four yards
level four
um
do you know how that works no
level four being the highest level most
dangerous
yeah the next level is super dome in san
diego i mean why'd they bring you to a
level four because my charges my charges
kidding
all that because those charges were so
intense they put you in with those
people you know
yeah holy [ __ ]
so when i catch the chain right i go
over there i catch the chain and uh this
guy's just like
[ __ ] kill you i'm gonna kill you like
that's we're gonna get you you know and
i'm just thinking the whole time like
this chain comes off i'm gonna rip this
guy's ass apart again you know what i
mean so i go into reception and we're in
a cell block it's like 360 degrees with
a gunner all this stuff some desks and
to come check you in and now ourselves
like we only we don't get out of
ourselves now until they intake us right
so now i'm in there it's like three
months
and uh
there's this this guy next door we start
talking through the vent to each other a
little bit you know
and uh we're playing chess and [ __ ] like
through the little vent
moon pieces around [ __ ] and they call me
out to the day to the thing talk to the
officers and this guy goes i don't know
this guy
again in the cell next to me right and i
walk past his cell and i hear him yell
like through the thing he's like hey bro
kick that cord over to me
and i might kick your cord over like
that of course right there kick that
cord over to me when you're coming by
and and i'm like
the [ __ ] do you want this cord for you
know it was like connected to this fan
right so when i come back i kicked this
cord over and i wasn't gonna do it but i
was like [ __ ] it right so i kicked this
cord over there and next thing you know
in the night i get this fish come
through right like it's a like they make
a like a string right with the thing
let's swing it out into your cell you
take this kite and you can read the
information on it or whatever you know
so kite it around to everybody and get
it to who they needed to get it to right
okay so this guy shoots this little
sheet kite over to me i open it up as a
[ __ ] sack of weed dude
right and i'm like i'm like that's why
this dude wanted that cord he took that
cord and he started a wick so he started
a fire and he had a bag of weed so now
he's smoking weed and the whole cell is
like full of weed bro and he shoots i
say bro i can't have this like i try to
shoot that [ __ ] back to him he's like
he's like nah you got to keep it you get
coffee with it you get whatever you need
you know and i'm like i'm like oh [ __ ]
okay you know so my other celly that was
in there he was like i'll take it and i
was like [ __ ] yeah take that [ __ ] so i
got a bunch of canteen and [ __ ] you know
like coffee and stuff for it
and uh
so this guy like really really was like
thankful i did it for him you know like
kick this cord so i never seen his face
like never seen this guy's face right
just hear him talking through the thing
and uh
so uh
the guy i caught the chain with
puts this hit on me like they want to
try and try and stab me right
so
it goes around to the other key holders
the [ __ ] guy next to me was a key
holder for the for the bloods she's a
black guy
because i kicked that cord over to him
he hit me up through the cell he's like
hey
he says is your name beanie
and i was like [ __ ] right
let's go back over
to the vent right and i said
no
and he goes like and he goes he goes oh
good
and i'm like oh good
right
and i'm like i'm like hey i said that
i said what if it was
and he goes what is it or not [ __ ]
i go it's not beanie i go it's benny and
he goes it's the same [ __ ]
i go like okay bro he's like hey i'm
gonna let you know they're gonna pop
this door and they're coming for you
and i was like really
i was like what do you mean he's like
they're going to come and get you and
this door pops you're going to pop this
door you're going to go to shower and
they're going to send some guys to come
and get you
my other celly he knows already he
didn't tell me
in order for that to go down they have
to tell your silly so your stellar can
stay out of the [ __ ] way oh wow so he
knows about it he's known about it
and now he tells me to the wall and now
i know he knows about it
you know what i mean and i'm living in
this room with this guy
so
door pops
my celly takes off running out of the
cell
so i just poke i just post it up at the
back of the cell just waiting you know
and sure [ __ ] two guys come flying in
one guy flying and trying to stab me and
then we're [ __ ] scrapping rapping all
over the place
fall out of the cell we're up the stairs
[ __ ] push the guy down the stairs we
fall down the stairs i'm tired as [ __ ]
like fighting two guys i'm tired i'm
lumped up a little bit
and i look over this way and i'm barely
breathing look over this way and all the
[ __ ] cops just watching they're just
watching oh my god so this other guy
come over he's kicking kicking kicking i
grab the other guy drag him on top of me
and i'm just choking him you know like
trying to use him to deflect this guy
from from getting at me right and then
realize this guy's out he's not even
awake
push him off me and now it's just me and
this guy and everybody in the cells
watching and all the cops watching so
just tear this [ __ ] guy's ass up
we leave
and this guy never got up
the guy was choking
never got up
just
eyes full of blood right
so
they send me to another cell block i go
in there there for a couple days
guard comes in
we're going to move you to to the
gymnasium so you move me to the
gymnasium
so now i'm out of the cell block i'm in
a gym with 300 guys can walk around i
get yard access all this stuff right
and the cop says
i really appreciate what you did for us
out there
he's like that was pretty [ __ ]
amazing and i'm just thinking to myself
like i want to get the [ __ ] out of here